Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Two, Episode Seven, Part Two.
Now, the duties of citizens.
First, conscription, værnepligt.
All men and women with Danish citizenship over 18 years of age who have residence or stay in Denmark must serve conscription for a period.
In practice, there is no need for all young people in an age group to serve their conscription.
If there are not enough volunteers, it is decided by lottery whether you must serve conscription.
If you fail to turn up for the service you are ordered to do, you can be punished with imprisonment.
If the outcome of the lottery is that you do not have to serve conscription, you have drawn a so-called free number, a frinummer.
Until the first of July, 2025, only men had conscription, and women could decide for themselves whether they wanted to serve, if they were declared suitable for it.
Conscription can be served in the Army, the Navy, the Air Force and the Danish Emergency Management Agency, and the service lasts eleven months.
The length of service has also varied through history.
In the period 2005 to 26, most conscripts served for four months.
As part of the wish to strengthen Danish defence, conscripts from February 2026 must, as a starting point, serve for 11 months.
If you for reasons of conscience do not wish to serve your conscription in the defence or the rescue service, you can become a conscientious objector, a militærnægter.
A conscientious objector can serve their conscription by doing other work for the benefit of society.
That can for example be in institutions for children, young people and the elderly, or in cultural institutions such as museums and theatres.
Second, civic office, borgerligt ombud, or just an ombud.
An ombud is a task, a hverv, which society can impose on a citizen.
Anyone who is appointed to such a task must accept it.
It can for example be sitting on a municipal council, if the citizen is elected, or serving as a lay judge, lægdommer, a juror or nævning, at a court.
Lay judges are ordinary people who help to judge in a criminal case.
They must both assess whether the accused person is guilty, and help decide what the punishment should be.
Anyone can apply to become a lay judge.
Third, punishment, straf.
If a citizen does not obey the law, they can often be punished.
It does, however, require that it directly appears from a law that the crime can be punished.
The most serious crimes are contained in the Criminal Code, straffeloven.
It has, among other things, provisions about sexual offences, crimes against life and limb, that is homicide and violence, and crimes of enrichment, theft and so on.
In Denmark, the age of criminal responsibility is 15 years.
That means children and young people under 15 cannot be punished for a crime.
This is because they are assessed as immature and unable to assess the consequences of their actions.
Children aged 10 to 14 who commit crimes can instead of punishment, for example, be ordered to do community service, to clean up after vandalism, or to be at home in a specific period of time.
The child can also be placed in a closed institution.
Cases about children aged 10 to 14 are handled by a special Youth Crime Board, Ungdomskriminalitetsnævn.
The usual punishments are fines and imprisonment.
Foreigners can also be sentenced to expulsion from Denmark if they commit crimes.
In the case of very serious crimes such as terrorism, Danish citizens can by a court judgment be deprived of their Danish citizenship.
A citizenship cannot, however, be taken away from a person if they would become stateless.
The death penalty cannot be imposed in Denmark.
The last executions in Denmark took place in the period 1945 to 50.
In total, 78 persons were sentenced to death for having helped the German occupying power during the war.
46 of the 78 death sentences were carried out.
The last execution for a crime committed in peacetime took place in 1892.
Finally, criminal cases and the police.
It is not the courts themselves, but only the prosecution service, anklagemyndigheden, that can bring a criminal case.
This follows from the Administration of Justice Act, retsplejeloven.
Certain less serious criminal cases must be brought by private persons, most often the one who is the victim of the crime.
This applies, for example, to cases about breaches of the peace and defamation.
The prosecution service is the public authority that on behalf of society decides whether charges are to be brought, and thereby whether a criminal case is to be brought before the courts at all.
After that, the courts decide whether the citizen is guilty and is to be punished.
A long series of smaller cases can be settled without the involvement of the courts by the offender accepting to pay a fine.
This is for example the case with many violations of the road traffic act.
If the fine is not paid, the case is brought before the courts.
The prosecution service is subject to the Ministry of Justice, which is led by the Minister of Justice.
The prosecution service consists of the Director of Public Prosecutions, the Rigsadvokat, who is the top leader of the prosecution service, as well as three state prosecutors and the chief constables.
The police are part of the state administration.
That means the state has overall responsibility for the police.
The prosecution service must convince the judges that the accused is guilty.
Every reasonable doubt must benefit the accused.
The police must through investigation obtain the necessary evidence.
If you want to report a crime, it must be reported to the police.
You do not normally have a duty to report a crime to the police.
Both police and prosecution service have a duty to be objective and ensure that it is the right persons who are punished, and that innocent people are not prosecuted.
It is the police who investigate criminal matters, but the courts control the lawfulness of the investigation the police carry out.
The Administration of Justice Act has rules about which interventions the police can make against a citizen when they investigate a case.
This can for example be searching a citizen's property.
The police must not use force during interrogation.
They cannot therefore force a person to give a statement.
Everyone is, however, obliged to give name, address and date of birth to the police.
If a citizen wants to complain about the behaviour of the police, a complaint can be made to the Independent Police Complaints Authority, Den Uafhængige Politiklagemyndighed.
The police can under certain conditions arrest a person who is reasonably suspected of a punishable offence.
If a citizen is arrested, they must be brought before a judge within 24 hours, one døgn.
Remember that number: twenty-four hours.
It is up to the judge to decide whether the citizen is to be released or remanded in custody while the police and the prosecution service investigate the case.
The judge can also choose to maintain the arrest for three times 24 hours, but that is only how long the arrest may be maintained afterwards.
Here is your recap for Episode Seven, and for Chapter Two.
The political freedoms are freedom of expression, assembly and association; censorship is forbidden; and only the courts decide whether the limits have been crossed.
Children have the right to free schooling in the folkeskole, and the constitution forbids discrimination based on faith or descent.
The European Convention on Human Rights became part of Danish law in 1992.
The Ombudsman is elected by the Folketing but cannot overrule an authority.
Folketing meetings are public, and courts can meet behind closed doors.
Conscription now applies to both men and women, since the first of July, 2025, and lasts eleven months from February 2026; a conscientious objector does other work for society.
A lay judge helps decide guilt and punishment.
The age of criminal responsibility is 15; children aged 10 to 14 are handled by the Youth Crime Board.
Denmark has no death penalty; the last executions were in 1945 to 50, with 46 of 78 sentences carried out, and the last in peacetime in 1892.
Only the prosecution service can bring a criminal case, under the Ministry of Justice.
The police must bring an arrested person before a judge within 24 hours; the judge can maintain the arrest for three times 24 hours.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
How long can the police hold an arrested person with legal residence in Denmark before the person must be brought before a judge?
Option A: Up to 1 døgn, one day and night.
Option B: Up to 3 døgn.
Option C: Up to 1 week.
[DA] Hvor længe kan politiet tilbageholde en anholdt person, der har lovligt ophold i Danmark, før personen skal stilles for en dommer?  A: I op til 1 døgn  |  B: I op til 3 døgn  |  C: I op til 1 uge
The answer is A: Up to 1 døgn, one day and night.
It appeared in 4 different exams, most recently in June 2026.
[DA] ✔ A: I op til 1 døgn
Question 2.
What is the age of criminal responsibility in Denmark?
Option A: 12 years.
Option B: 15 years.
Option C: 18 years.
[DA] Hvad er den kriminelle lavalder i Danmark?  A: 12 år  |  B: 15 år  |  C: 18 år
The answer is B: 15 years.
It appeared in 5 different exams, most recently in November 2025.
[DA] ✔ B: 15 år
Question 3.
Who decides whether a citizen is to be remanded in custody?
Option A: A lawyer.
Option B: A judge.
Option C: A police officer.
[DA] Hvem afgør, om en borger skal varetægtsfængsles?  A: En advokat  |  B: En dommer  |  C: En politibetjent
The answer is B: A judge.
It appeared in the November 2024 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: En dommer
Question 4.
Who has conscription in Denmark?
Option A: Only men.
Option B: Only women.
Option C: Both men and women.
[DA] Hvem har værnepligt i Danmark?  A: Kun mænd  |  B: Kun kvinder  |  C: Både mænd og kvinder
The answer is C: Both men and women.
It appeared in the June 2026 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Både mænd og kvinder
That's the end of this part.
Well done.